- UH, GREETINGS,
ADVENTURERS.
- GREETINGS.
- AS YOU ALL
CAN SEE HERE,
WE HAVE A NEW TRAVELER
IN OUR RANKS.
UH, THIS IS
MY COUSIN TYRELL,
AND HE WILL BE CONTROLLING
THE PLAYER CHARACTER.
- HIS NAME IS KANYE.
HE'S A GIANT, YO.
- [nervously laughing]
UH, DEAR COUSIN...
TRADITIONALLY, A--A GIANT
IS NOT ASSUMED BY A PLAYER.
IT IS A
CHAOTIC, EVIL--
- YEAH, BUT I WANNA
BE A GIANT, YO.
ALL BIG.
- OH, OKAY. FINE.
[laughing]
WELL, TRAVELERS, YOU ARE JOINED
ON YOUR ADVENTURE TODAY
BY A GIANT
NAMED KANYE.
NOW WHEN LAST WE LEFT YOU,
YOU WERE AT THE INN
OF THE NORTH STAR
IN THE TOWN OF ISLEDOR.
HOW DO YOU BEGIN
YOUR ADVENTURE?
- I WANNA GET
SOME BITCHES.
WHERE THE CLUB AT
AT ISLEDOR, YO?
- TYRELL, THIS IS
HIGHLY UNUSUAL.
I THINK THE GUYS PROBABLY
JUST WANNA GO ON THE QUEST--
- UM, STEPHEN?
- YES?
- I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN
KANYE THE GIANT IN HIS QUEST.
- SERIOUSLY?
ALL RIGHT.
THE TWO OF YOU
ENTER THE TAVERN.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
- KANYE THE GIANT
ORDERS ALIZE.
- HMM, SAYS
THE BARKEEP.
UH, I KNOW NOT OF THIS FOREIGN
BEVERAGE OF WHICH YOU SPEAK.
PERHAPS YOU'D ENJOY
AN ELVEN ALE?
- NO, WE BOTH
WANT THE ALIZE.
- ALIZE DOES NOT EXIST
IN THIS WORLD.
- KANYE THE GIANT
SLAPS THAT BITCH.
- OH!
- KANYE THE GIANT ATTEMPTS
TO SLAP THE BARTENDER. HERE.
THE BARTENDER
IS HALF-HOBBIT
AND VERY NIMBLE,
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO ROLL AN 18 OR ABOVE TO HIT.
20.
- BLIP.
SLAP THAT HOBBIT'S
[bleep] OFF, YO.
- OKAY. GOLLIN
THE CLERIC,
WOULD YOU CARE TO RESTRAIN
KANYE THE GIANT
BEFORE THE TOWN GUARD
IS CALLED?
- UH, I GRAB MONEY
OUT OF THE REGISTER.
- BUT--BUT--BUT GOLLIN
THE CLERIC IS LAWFUL GOOD.
THIS ACT OF THIEVERY
WOULD DISHONOR HIS GODS.
- HEY, MAN.
THE ONLY GODS
IS MONEY AND BITCHES, DUDE.
- AH! I ACCEPT KANYE
THE GIANT'S GODS, AND, UH...
YEAH, I-I-I STEAL
SOME OF THE MONEY TOO.
- YOU TOO?
OKAY, WOULD YOU NOW LIKE
TO CONTINUE YOUR QUEST
FOR THE LANDS OF CALDAHAR?
- FELLAS...
WE CAME HERE
FOR BITCHES.
WHERE THE BITCHES AT?
- ALL RIGHT, YOU SEE A BEVY
OF WELL-ENDOWED WENCHES.
- GREAT, I GRAB THEM BITCHES,
AND WE ALL GO IN MY SUV.
- FINE. KANYE THE GIANT,
UDAR THE DWARF,
AND GOLLIN THE CLERIC
CLIMB INTO HIS SUV
WITH THEIR BITCHES
AND THEIR ILL-GOTTEN GAINS.
- AND OUR ALIZE.
PLUS KANYE THE GIANT
PUTS HIS DEMO CD
IN THE CD PLAYER--
- NO, HE DOESN'T.
THERE ARE NO CDs
IN THIS WORLD!
YOU KNOW WHAT?
DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT.
- ALL RIGHT.
I GUESS I'M
THE DUNGEON MASTER NOW.
THE EYE OF ONA
OPENS UP...
16 TITTIES
FALL OUT.
- YEAH! [laughing]
- HURRAH!